hey what's up YouTube skiff in here
we're gonna show you another thing about
my 2012 f-150 EcoBoost truck this will
work on the 500 or the EcoBoost what
we're gonna do is we're gonna program a
new key to start this engine programming
the key fob the buttons and programming
the chip that's inside of this key are
two different things okay so what we're
gonna do is I'm going to show you how to
program a third key now keep in mind
this only works if you have two current
keys you have to have two current
working keys if you don't have two
working keys you're gonna have to take
your new key to the Ford dealership and
pay them about seventy-five bucks I'm
going to show you how to do it for free
if you already have two keys it's really
really easy okay so the process goes
like this you're gonna put your key
number one in the ignition for five to
ten seconds I usually just go until it
stops beeping and then I pull it out now
take key number two these are your
original keys it's already work and
within ten seconds put that second one
in or between four to 10 seconds
officially I go five to 10 seconds now
to get your third one program this is
your new your new key program within 20
seconds you have to put it in and turn
it did you see did you hear the lock
cycle that's the truck programming to
this key so now this key will work in
this truck to start the truck so what
I'm going to do is take it out and I'll
just show you that it starts it and
we've
programmed it to work with this key
right and that's all there is to it
really there is a process for
programming the key fobs as well but now
the chip that's inside this key will
work with this truck and then you want
to get it cut somewhere local locksmith
or something like that so the reason I
did this is because I have remote start
in the truck now and I had to get new
key fobs and they come right on the key
so I got the new keys cut now I have
four keys say thanks for watching and
have a good day guys